chaque jour on met en lumière dans cette
émission si une bonne action du jour et
aujourd'hui on a avec nous le shaq
adjoint de la réanimation à l'hôpital
cochin
le président de la fondation one to one
et c'est la bonne action du jour c'est
quelqu'un vraiment que j'admire
énormément avec vous allez admirer vos
cibles quand il va nous expliquer ce
qu'il fait il est vraiment je peux vous
dire il après vraiment trois minutes
pour nous parce qu'il est débordé vous
imaginez bien c'est le professeur
jean-daniel chiche qui est avec nous
merci d'être avec nous professeur merci
d'être là vraiment c'est un honneur pour
nous on sait que vous avez énormément de
travail et on voulait absolument parler
de votre fondation parce que c'est
important pour nous de mettre en lumière
et chose importante surtout en ce moment
merci d'être là professeur bien c'est
cyril bonsoir alors professeur avant de
parler de la fondation j'aimerais
vraiment parce qu'il ya plein de jeunes
qui nous regardent et c'est vrai qu'en
ce moment on entend parler de
réanimation et de services de
réanimation alors qu'avant on
n'entendait pas du tout parler
j'aimerais vraiment que vous nous
expliquer parce que c'est important
d'apprendre des choses aussi et tous les
jeunes qui nous regardent qu'ils
apprennent des choses
qu'est ce que c'est que la réanimation
et comment se retrouve en réanimation et
qu'est ce qu'un service de réanimation
alors un service de réanimation c'est un
service ou nova lorsque votre ville est
en danger c'est à dire que en fait vous
envient notre vie on est tous très
heureux on regarde qui nous amusent à
demain dommage les cartes aussi je vais
faire cela
et puis d'un coup ils font un coup de
téléphone d'un ami daran qui vous dit
pas cette personne que j'aime là
maintenant elle est en réanimation et on
sait pas si demain va exister pour cette
personne et on sa vie est en danger
parce que un de ses organes semaine pu
marcher ça peut être pour plein de
raisons différent aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup de cette épidémie de
l'infection à coville mais ça peut être
pour plein de raisons différentes
et là vous allez le client ouais à
leasing et là je vais être pris en
charge par une équipe qui va assurer le
fonctionnement de tous vos organes et
faire en sorte que vous puissiez
survivre à cette épreuve et repartir
pour une deux
samedi c'est pour ça qu'elle s'appelle
wang wang cette fondation dont les
positions 1 de mots on a tous ces
merveilleux projets pour demain 0 notre
vie est suspendue à un style le temps
est suspendu aux dépens d'une équipe de
réanimation dont l'objectif c'est de
vous ramener à 1 à 0.5 pour que vous
ayez une deuxième vie donc en fait les
services de réanimation ça sert à ça ça
sert à vous donner une deuxième date
d'anniversaire et à ce que vous puissiez
profiter pleinement de cette deuxième
vie alors juste vous êtes le chef
adjoint de l'hôpital cochin à paris
quelle est la situation actuellement au
service réanimation mais aujourd'hui on
ne vous l'entendez on est débordé on a
de plus en plus de patients les nos
hôpitaux sont pleins on se bat pour
accueillir tous les patients qui ont
besoin de soins en réanimation à cause
de cette épidémie on aère multiplier nos
capacités d'accueil
on a été très inventif et créatif pour
créer des services de réanimation et
fait des lits de réanimation un peu
partout mais on est débordés parce qu'on
voit que laval progressé que le nombre
de lits dont on va avoir besoin continue
à augmenter on commence à parler de 2800
3010 simplement sur la région parisienne
alors justement confesseur chiche
est ce que pour les téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent c'est vrai qu'il ya des
chiffres et c'est vrai que ça va leur
parler aussi
je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
disent pourquoi en france on a besoin
d'être confiné c'est aussi parce qu'on a
besoin que les gens restent chez eux
pour qu'il n'y ait pas un afflux massif
dans les réanimations parce qu'on n'a
pas assez de lits est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner à peu près le ratio par
personne de lit par exemple dans un pays
comme comme l'allemagne où il est dans
un pays comme l'italie doit payer comme
comme la france pour qu'on se fasse une
idée
oui on dit par exemple en allemagne il
appréhende beaucoup mieux la crise parce
que c'est très simple on la moyenne en
europe
c'est 11,5 lits de réanimation pour
100000 habitants ça c'est la moyenne en
france on y à 11,6 d'accord juste au
dessus de la moyenne
en italie ils sont à 12 mai en allemagne
5h29
29 oui et donc ça quand une vraie
différence et c'est pour ça qu
effectivement ils sont capables de faire
face à cette crise avec moins de morts
moins nord qu'en france le nombre de cas
aujourd'hui en héros
l'allemagne est plus important que le
nombre de cas en france alors janvier
vous nous avez parlé de one on one s
comment vous voulez que tu vois là qui
souhaitez-vous mobilisés avec cet appel
aux dons et comment on peut contribuer
voilà à cet appel aux dons d'aujourd'hui
à vous tous on veut on veut mobiliser
toutes les personnes qui nous regardent
et les patrons d'entreprises tous les
gens qui veulent changer les choses en
font tout à fait deux ans qu'on dit
partout que la réanimation c'est un
sujet que c'est un enjeu il faut se
mobiliser pour ça et on a effectivement
besoin d'argent parce que il ya
énormément de générosité des français je
me trouve ça absolument merveilleux pour
la recherche pour les hôpitaux de façon
générale nation mais il ya un vrai sujet
sur la réanimation qui est un tout petit
c'est tout petit service et qui
aujourd'hui sont vraiment les endroits
où toutes les toutes les vies peuvent
être sauvées vont l'être par ses équipes
et on a besoin donc un bouton spécifique
m'empêcher pour les services de
réanimation pour qu'on puisse faire
progresser cette spécialité et sauver
toutes les détenus peuvent être sauvés
alors regardez regardez cette petite
vidéo one on one
et voilà vous le voyez pour faire un don
à la fondation one one www points donnés
point one one one tiré au one
voilà et vous allez voir ça va
s'afficher justement à l'écran regardez
cette petite vidéo et je vous le dis la
ranimation c'est très très très
important ça peut sauver des vies ça
sauve des vies regardez
[Musique]
m
et
one one merci professeur chiche d'avoir
été avec nous voilà on va afficher bien
sûr le site a bien sûr juste en bas en
liner et merci d'avoir été avec nous de
vous avoir expliqué les choses et je
sais que vous avez très peu de temps
vous laisse travailler et on vous
souhaite voilà de pouvoir on sauver le
maximum de vies et voilà on vous savez
qu'on est avec vous à fond il ya un élan
de générosité incroyable mais vrai il ya
plein de gens voilà qui essaie de faire
des choses pour vous c'est vrai qu'on se
dit on n'y pensait pas avant mais
aujourd'hui on va y penser tout le temps
maintenant à tout le personnel
hospitalier et mine de rien quand on
verra réanimation maintenant ça nous
dira encore plus quelque chose et on
dira voilà que les services de
réanimation faut pas les laisser tomber
merci pour votre aide merci pour votre
aide il ya bientôt